glücklich war dass den start geht jetzt
hier nicht sterben brauche ich noch
hallo leute ich ist wieder einmal waren
und heute komme ich mit einem neuen
video um die ecke was vielleicht zu
einem regelmäßigen format mit und zwar
möchte ich herausfinden was denn so im
november
der heiße scheiß ist was wollen die
menschen wonach streben sie und was ist
der sinn des lebens all diese fragen
werden wir heute beantworten ich bin
instruments ich muss ganz genau darüber
bescheid wissen was der heiße scheiß es
was die leute wollen was ist cool was
kommt und da ich das immer nicht weiß
finden wir es heute heraus da es das
erste video zu diesem neuen format ist
wollen wir mal schauen wohin es sich so
entwickelt mit uns was mich als fashion
blogger ganz besonders interessiert ist
was trägt man im november fashiontrends
november autumn fashion ideas von
instyle die internetseite von instyle
ist wirklich allerletzte chance on me
versteht ihr was ich meine mit fashion
trends ich möchte jetzt nicht
irgendwelche laufsteg models sehen mit
klamotten die man eh nicht tragen würde
ich möchte wirklich so teile sehen wo
man sagt die knie shirts hosen tragen
jetzt alle oder diese komische
kapitänsmütze aber sowas gibts auch
nicht immer michelle obama trägt ein
holzfällerhemd und die ganze welt rastet
aus verdis nabucco want to all day long
auf jeden fall 180 dollar schuhe von
bloomingdale's 280 dollar schuhe 335
dollar schuhe verkauft sich dann so
teure schuhe die sehen nicht mal gut aus
passion locker wember fashionblog aus
berlin ich möchte nicht wissen wie ich
am strand gut aussehen
was trägt man im november gartenkalender
november das ist jetzt echt meine frage
an euch wie findet man heraus was man
gerade so tragen soll also ich wüsste
nicht wie ich das jetzt herausfinden
sollte also welche mützen sind gerade
eben oder gibt es irgendwelche fashion
blogger seiten oder so die empfehlen
könnt wo man so immer mal wieder gucken
kann der aktuellen trends weil ich muss
sagen ich kann mich nie anziehen also
ich ziehe das an was mir so gefällt aber
ich würde mich auch gerne mal so ein
bisschen experimenteller und so ein
bisschen hipper anziehen kann es aber
einfach nicht manchmal absolut keine
ahnung gehabt was gerade gewollt ist
damit die knie schlitz hosen also diese
jack nicholson halt raus kam ich habe
sie ein jahr später quasi entdeckt dass
man dazu trägt und dann habe ich sie
auch für mich entdeckt aber vorher alles
schon getragen und dachte mir so warum
sind da schmerzen in den knien
das sagt man teilt man jetzt bin ich
selber sein opfer man trägt fieldings
elegante hosenanzüge dicke jacken
us-team zu dicke jacken das habe ich
schon öfter gesehen caro franken fransen
protest mode so beschreibe ich auch
meinen kleidungsstil protest mode und
sand und silber metallic wenn ihr damit
nicht sagen dass man einfach alles
gerade tragen kann und das ist alles
richtig ist zwar ist aber auch erst mal
genug mit feschen wir wollen jetzt
herausfinden welche kinostart gibt es im
november wie jones heute kommt die reise
der pinguine zweihaus okay wenn ihr die
reise der pinguine nicht gesehen habt
das ist ungefähr der allerschönste film
der welt und der trauerhalle einfach und
das leben von pinguin zeit und sie haben
so ein hartes leben die werden von ron
gefressen und die papas müssen sich um
die kümmern und die mamas müssen voll an
dann müssen sie ab essen und dann müssen
die anderen hungern das ist so voller
michael raffl wiesenhagen mitgenommen
haben als ich weiß gar nicht wann der
erste rausgekommen ist aber die reise
der pinguine werde ich mehr im november
auf jeden fall anschauen welchen film
ich mir diesen monat unbedingt anschauen
möchte ist mord im orientexpress weil
dieser trailer so cool aussieht und ich
glaube es spielt sogar johnny depp mit
es spielt johnny depp mit dem erinnert
mich an polar express und ice breaker
jetzt kann man zu dem film sagen seid
mord im zug und einen detektiv findet
heraus wer es war und dann sind halt
ganz viele in diesem abteil und dann ja
darum geht der film habe ich auch noch
nicht gesehen hat deswegen will ich
unbedingt schlauer fuchs was ist fix
fuchs es gab mal eine zeit da konnte
rocky sie alle haben er spielte
französische chansons und die frauen
schmelzen dahin
das ist zwar längst vorbei aber der
traum vor seiner tür steht aber als
torwart sei natürlich wird er noch
einmal herausgefordert der junge mann
der seinen sohn zu sein weiß nicht wie
man frauen flachgelegt und rockin will
soll es ihnen beibringen so gehen sie
auf die jagd junge schöne frauen soll es
sein
wow ich weiß auf jeden fall im november
fiel ins kino gehen werde weil sehr
viele gute wege herauskommen wie zum
beispiel barbie die magie der delfine
welche feiertage erwarten uns im
november erst wenn man aber natürlich
alle heiligen wo nur der süden
deutschlands frei hatte juve kam öfter
november martinstag 19 november
volkstrauertag 22 november buß und
bettag als kind habe ich immer buß und
bettag gelesen dann dachte ich mann soll
im bett und am 26
beim messe totensonntag kuriose
feiertage im november das ist was wir
wollen siebter november umarme einen
bären tag wird gern mal bern um aber der
würde mich so was von umbringen am 8
nationaler tag der putzfrau und da
werdet ihr alle eure wohnung ja macht
nur wenn man sich euer zimmer oder eine
wohnung putzt dann eher die putzfrauen
nicht ganz verstanden und wenn wir es
dass servtag elfter novembertag des
origami da bekommt ihr die hausaufgabe
ein origami zu basteln zwölfter
novembertag der schlechten wortspiele
könnte jetzt bitte auf rhodos instagram
account gehen und ihm sagen dass am 12
november sein persönlicher feiertag in
style center november internationaler
tag der zungen recht 10.7.2 unterzucker
zum zoo fischers fritz frisch fischers
fritz fischers fritz fischt frische
fische frische fische fischers fritz
laut haut mit blaukraut bleibt blaukraut
bleibt blaukraut und brautkleid bleibt
brautkleid
jetzt sind da novembertag der
gewürzgurke an dem tag müsst ihr die
gruppe auf dem cheeseburger essen auch
wenn ihr sie nicht möglich da november
post einen kühlschrank
ich glaube wir im leben die routine
fehlt muss einfach diese ganzen
feiertage nehmen und danach sein leben
ordnen sechzehnter novembertag das fast
food in den usa
ich glaube es ist jeden tag tag des fast
food in den usa hier sonst wenn man
feiert ein einzigartiges talent tag ich
werde also den ganzen tag geschlafen
wäre das nicht auch eine coole challenge
wenn man mal einen monat danach leben
würde wie tage werden jetzt nicht mal
trösten
vielleicht mache ich das einfach mal im
november wisst ihr was macht meine
kleinen channel für november ich werde
so viele feiertage wie möglich feiern
indem ich sie halt feier aus höhere
dinge tun die zu diesem feiertag passen
dann kommt noch das alles filmen kann
und dann gibt es am 30 november ein
ich feiere alle feiertage feier video
okay wir haben auf jeden fall
festgestellt dass es ganz viele
feiertage gibt die kein mensch braucht
aber vielleicht machen sie das leben ein
bisschen schöner ein bisschen
interessanter
vor allem wenn man irgendwie vielleicht
ja so wer feiert das jetzt mal ganz
wer bei diesen ganzen
feiertage ich sag euch ich werde diesen
monat alle feiertage feiern und euch
dann sagen es sich öfters komplett ab
und ich glaube das war es jetzt auch
erstmal mit der ersten folge weil ich
noch nicht ganz weiß wie das jetzt so
raus kommt und ob es mir gefällt und ob
man noch sachen hinzufügen sollte sollte
man definitiv aber wir werden mal
schauen was das video bringen ihr habt
gerade gesehen also werdet ihr jetzt
sagen können hey vanessa mach weiter so
oder vanessa dieses video machte ich
mich so schreibt es mir gerne in die
kommentare da ist die erste folge ist
von diesem format was noch kein
wirkliches format ist denn es gibt ja
nur eine folge davon würde es mir recht
weiterhelfen zu wissen was euch so
gefällt vielleicht keine auch noch
themen ein zu denen ich etwas sagen kann
also ich hatte jetzt mode kinostarts und
kuriose feiertage vielleicht gibt es ja
noch etwas anderes wie konzerte und mehr
fällt mir dazu nicht ein aber auf jeden
fall gibt bescheid wenn ihr noch mehr
wissen wollt ansonsten könnt ihr hier
noch zwei andere videos von mir schauen
oder ihr könnt mich abonnieren das wäre
richtig cool bitte abonniert mich denn
dann verpasst ihr kein neues video und
ihr könnt die glocke aktivieren oh mein
gott was die glocke ja wenn nämlich
abonniert haben eine glocke die könnte
drücken und dann verpasst ihr kein video
wenn dann sagt auf youtube ein video
hochgeladen und dann könnt ihr immer
ganz schnell drauf klicken und erster
schreiben und vielleicht seid ihr auch
dann irgendwann erster und ich glaube
jetzt scheiße
bis dahin tschüss